good morning John it's Tuesday March 6th
and I am entirely surrounded by 100
peeps we found the peeps the bunnies
kind of full size right I think I'm
gonna get the bunnies because they're
sort of more swallowable they look more
like a shape that won't choke me to
death I've just discovered something
very interesting it says that for
bunnies are 31 grams and that they
contain 33 grams of carbohydrates
there's actually more sugar than there
is money in these bunnies good news on
the cheapskate front each one of these
things is only 99 cents so I'm going to
get out of store paying exactly six
dollars so now target has six of my
dollars and I have 100 of their peeps I
would also like to announce that I've
completed the first Brotherhood 2.0 book
club book yes I finish we wish to inform
you that tomorrow we will be killed with
our families by Philip Gourevitch and
since I don't have time to discuss that
book and eat 100 peeps I'm going to
discuss the book while eating 100 peeps
on your mark get set now there's some
discussion below to point out about we
were we wish to inform you tomorrow
because our families know how it's a
book designed to make you feel guilty
about something I already happen
there's no use crying over spilt milk
one gallon per every dead person eight
hundred thousand gallon to milk well
what Philip garbages book was really
about was understanding that something
happened in Rwanda something very
significant on a worldwide scale unlike
in people only half the slum why are you
that beyond acknowledging it it's about
understanding how something like that
could happen I mean in a matter of days
800,000 people were killed all you have
to have the right cocktail
of international indecision local
alcoholism long-term racism and a couple
of inflammatory people with control over
the media and there's absolutely
possible for completely normal healthy
people to become genocide Oh maniacs to
commit the worst crime that so far
humanity is capable of committing it
wasn't just bad people killing bad
people was a bad situation and that when
we can recognize those ingredients being
poured together in the stew again we can
put a lid on it before the fumes reach a
nationwide fervor and create another
genocidal scenario world governments
need to recognize it is possible and
that individual citizens do direct
message possible so that they can
pressure their governments ah and that
was not me almost puking that's just the
bad taste of the peep Oh 5/16 not gonna
be able to finish this one it's too late
I'm so glad six minutes is up that
people's just sticking to my finger uh
and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna eat this
half a peep I add that many which
honestly I think is pretty good I'm
feeling kind of jittery
I really haven't eaten anything else
today that is that is all I've eaten
that's one hundred percent of the food
I've eaten today oh oh it doesn't feel
very good though oh oh I can't I can't
see like huh I hate their little eyes so
now I have to go online and contribute
eighty seven point five dollars to the
Brotherhood 2.0 foundation to decrease
suck levels worldwide think what we
could do with that money
plus the twenty I already don't
and plus the 20 you already donated it's
like one hundred and twenty seven point
five dollars whoa
this video is longer than four minutes
please do not punish me because I'm
doing a punishment and we haven't
actually made that an official rule yet
but I'm making it a rule now from now on
videos must be less than four minutes
and this is the last one that will be
more than four minutes that is a rule as
of tomorrow which is when I will see you
who wants peeps I offer